[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys
wells heute ist ein ganz besonderes
video für mich denn auch meinen heutigen
gast habe ich mich schon so lange
gefreut ich folgte schon relativ lange
und ich liebe sie so sehr und ich liebe
sie auch schon so lange und wir haben es
aber tatsächlich nur ein mal in unserem
leben gesehen zwar vor kurzem aber ich
habe echt das gefühl ich kenne sie
einfach schon immer und ewig heute ist
sie da die bezaubernde wunderschöne
herzallerliebste matmour silke tesch
[Applaus]
ich konnte nicht schlafen weil ihr habt
sagte nicole etwas hättest du gern was
sollen wir backen und was wolltest du
backen ich wollte eigentlich eine also
erst mal hallo ich freue mich sehr hier
zu sein total und die ursprungsidee war
das reale bip langstrumpf tagen ja nicht
statt
bisher tun wir gerade weihnachten und
pippi langstrumpf ist für mich schon so
erste frühjahr/sommer fasching karneval
ganzes jahr
aber nicht so starken vorstand habe ich
dachte so für ein adventssonntag nur
vielleicht ist es okay was zu einer
ordnung das war trotzdem richtig richtig
gut meine stärken liegen jetzt nicht so
im backen mit dem kochen ist kein
problem aber backen ist jetzt so ein
bisschen tricky ja das kriegen wir hin
ist eigentlich ganz einfach schaut zu
und ich lerne ich adoptiere heute ja und
den die colette also für diejenigen die
sie nicht kennen wobei ich denke die
meisten kennen sie einfach schon ich
kenne sie zum beispiel durch ihren
wöchentlichen dortiger mustac der findet
auf instagram stadt und auf ihrer app
und darstellen dir ja zuschauer anonym
fragen genau oder durch marken von
problemen liebe partnerschaft und alles
was dazugehört
die schönen seiten
die komplizierten weiten und dann klappt
mich darüber dass immer auseinander das
macht viel spaß und ich habe echt schon
viel gelernt gerade so
zwischenmenschliches wie man mit
gewissen situationen umgeht hat auch
gelernt wie man gewisse situationen
besser analysieren kann deuten und
werten kann also ich finde das schon
zuvor also jeder der mich kennt guckt
euch einfach an aber eine bitte guckt
euch nicht nur an sondern abonniert auf
den kanada danke ich freue mich sehr
über die über jeden und jede freue ich
mich sehr und ich muss sagen ich hab
dachte ja immer das sein podcast soll
ich dann halt immer donnerstags so da
sitzt auf der couch oder meist hier in
der küche und gucke mir das immer an und
er hört ja immer nur mit und da dachte
er immer okay die toilette es hat ein
podcast dabei gucke ich mir immer die
stories an und er hat auch immer fleißig
mit und in manchen sie dort so merkel
der mann hat zugehört wer das ist mal
was ganz besonderes wenn männer auch zu
hören weil das eher die seltenheit ist
aber mir liegt schon sehr sehr viel
daran weil ich glaube dass es das fängt
die für jedes herz was dabei ist ja und
die leute die können was lernen die kann
ein bisschen schmunzeln vielleicht auch
etwas zu lachen haben oder zu weinen und
solange sie ihnen unterhält freue ich
mich ich finde es richtig schön ja aber
ansonsten hast du auch machst du auch
comedy ist normalerweise immer auf tour
bist buchautorin also so ein
komplettprogramm ja ja ich multitasking
die frau ja also ich bin
entertainerin durch und durch mit leib
und seele und köchin eigentlich auch
nicht so wie ich das klingt eigentlich
so ja es ist ja auch schon alles gut
portioniert ja wie schützt das gleich
nur ineinander und dann läuft der laden
ja so ungefähr also ich hab mir gedacht
wir machen jetzt zum adventssonntag eine
schöne torte die aussieht wie eine kerze
und man kann das ja auch dann so machen
dass man vielleicht zum erster band eine
kerze parkt oder zum 22 das könnt ihr
machen wie ihr möchtet größe höhe dicke
breite farbe alles entscheidet ihr
selbst so geschmacklich habe ich ein
bisschen nachgeforscht was sie gerne mag
und ich habe jetzt hier einfach so einen
wahllos teig mit zimt ausgesucht und
cranberries aber auch da könnt ihr stadt
wahllisten mandeln in kokons nehmen die
cranberries weglassen oder dazu gehen
ganz wie ihr brett
ja kirschen so saurik
kirche
schattenmorellen
schatten forellen ja nicht ganz aber so
ähnlich so ganz ganz saures genau und
für den teig brauchen wir sechs eier 300
gramm zucker etwas salz einen esslöffel
zimt etwas vanille extrakt 200 gramm
walnüsse jeweils 300 gramm butter milch
um sonnenblumenöl 150 gramm cranberries
und die nimmt 450 gramm mehl backpulver
oder verwendet einfach meinen backen da
ist das backpulver schon jetzt passt mal
auf das hier ist das backen von meiner
freundin sally gibt es beim little
kauft euch dass ich würde direkt auch
eine ganze chargen mit nach hause nehmen
kann man nie genug haben denn quasi wenn
ich das jetzt hier an preise dann ist es
morgen so viel so ausverkauft ich würde
jetzt auf pause drücken und losrennen
und alles kaufen wie bei alba sally
draufsteht immer kaufen gott ist denkt
kopf herum lernt das platz im auch sehr
viel und gerade ich die kleine back
nächste freunde ja mit accessoires
mitzunehmen habe ich brauche auch hier
so gut zu heulen wenn ihr hier in die
schubladen guckt ihr habt ja gar keine
ahnung moment ich muss das mal gerade
aufklären also ich bin hier in dieser
studie gekommen ich kenne das ja sonst
auch immer nur von youtube das ist viel
größer als man eigentlich denkt das ist
ein bisschen wie disneyland und wenn man
hier in die schubladen guckt da gibt es
gar bild da ist ein sticker drauf da
steht dann draufgabe
so sortiert ist das und wenn ihr meint
ihr hat nur einen pinken scharia 500
stück dafür hier in der schublade das
liegt auch alles so mit der wasserwaage
nebeneinander so sieht es nämlich hier
aus sehr ernst okay kommt ja wir legen
los und dann können wir uns gleich noch
mehr kennenlernen und beschnuppern
ok also das ist ein ganz normaler
rührteig früher hat man den fiel auf mit
butter gemacht mache auch gern mal so
ein bitterer tag für marmorkuchen aber
für so trocken die einfach auch gelingen
sicher sein sollen muss ich sagen
nämlich ganz gern öl und ich würde sagen
du bugs warum keine mutter weil
normalerweise müsste ich jetzt erst die
butter mit dem zucker schaumig rühren
und dann die eier einzeln dazu und dann
kann passieren dass dir diese masse
gewinnt und der teig hier mit öl mit
buttermilch der wird auch so ein
bisschen luftiger okay
hier gerne eier sogar
eingeben ich gebe auch direkt hier
ist wie big brother
kwh
ja dann wandel extrakt
rainer wirtz ist natürlich ja das war ja
auch gar nix also
da kannst du so bleiben lassen
und zahlt ist auch immer wichtig so und
dann verlieren wir das ist ja das rother
kleine prise salz die macht es dann ja
die macht wirklich als so ein viertel
teelöffel mache ich da dazu perfekt dann
schmeckt der teig einfach gut
und jetzt einfach für fünf bis zehn
minuten richtig schön weiß cremig
gerührt
auf alle leute bestimmt ja
weißt du was wir können die wahl waren
mit dem handkurbel
[Musik]
so sieht es jetzt aus schönweiß krieg
hältst du das jetzt über den kopf bittet
passanten gegen
aber wir könnten ja aber es läuft wird
es dann alles über das machen wir nur
bei einstellen aber das ist ja schon
hammer existiert schon so lecker aus
wenn man das übrigens erwärmen oder also
praktisch mit hitze so dass die eier
salmonellen und so weiter so bisschen
pasteurisiert sind und noch bissl säure
zufügt dann wäre das eigentlich so eine
zabaione soa zuckermasse bohrhammer bis
man auch das müssen wir nicht mal waren
blieb dabei ohne
den rest erledigen wir mit schneebesen
dafür brauchen wir den hätte ich mir was
ich jetzt hier die fans regelt um sich
das mit der luft mich zu verbauen sehr
groß siehst du sagst du kannst nicht
backen ich gucke deine videos immer also
hab ich dann so auf aber so ein bisschen
glück dazu stehen ja weil das gute ist
er wirklich wir haben wir jetzt so viel
luft eingeschlagen und die luft dürfen
wir jetzt nicht kaputt schlagen und
wichtig ist dass man mehl nicht solange
ein rührt du liebst es aber rein
normalerweise muss man sieben mit
backpulver vermischen und sieben aber
das ist meine bank mail das ist so ganz
fallen das musst du gar nicht mehr sehen
deswegen ist es echt richtig gut
faustregel jetzt flüssigkeiten zuerst
nein der ofen ist auch schon vorgeheizt
es ist auch immer wichtig damit der
kuchen nicht rum steht weil wenn der
teig herumsteht und auf den ofen wartet
dann dann geht die luft aus
das kannst jetzt damit so ein bisschen
einrühren
[Musik]
das macht es so gut ja ich gebe ja extra
wie ich gucke mir alles ab und dann
mache ich das nächste woche meine
eigenen youtube kanal und ich hör auf
den dirty tones du machst den dreck oder
fragt anja superstar alles in safe wir
könnten wirklich mal rollen
ja oh gott und dann würde ich echt mal
gerne sehen dass zu fragen weil die so
landen bei mir ist gab es schon dinge
die ich wo ich dachte
und haben nicht nur wir klopfen nicht
okay ich werde in interviews immer
gefragt was die krasseste frau habe ich
hier gespielt habe ich kann das gar
nicht sagen es war das normalisiert sich
auch alles im laufe der jahre
stand also ich hab schon ein krasser
dinge gehört bei dir und der lärm
staffelstart von denen ich nichts wusste
weißt du die leute weil sie das von
außen betrachtet sind wir sind und immer
ganz oft schockiert was was ich mir
fragen gestellt bekomme man darf aber
nicht vergessen die fragen werden von
menschen gestellt ja von ganz normalen
menschen
dieser welt rum laufen und dann weißt du
auch erstmal was in seinem leben
passiert menschen so an dass man nie
nach außen trägt
guck mal das heißt so richtig schön
gemacht jetzt geben wir das mädel dazu
und das wird jetzt nur noch so lange
untergehoben ist alles vermengt ist und
das wurde nie kommen also mit dem
bildnis und dann könnt ihr gleich den
teig entweder auf einem backblech backen
auf einem herkömmlichen backblech oder
mit einem back rahmen und später sagen
diese kreise sie hierfür die kerze
brauchen ausstechen und erlebt einfach
so wie wir gleich so kleine bugs ich
niemand diese bürger ringe und da haben
wir gleich direkt eine fläche kreise und
müssen nichts nachstehen soll jetzt geht
es aber hart daran jetzt ist es zum
finish kommen
ich möchte das schon
wenn man das hört ja da wird ja immer
mehr
übernehmen man sieht jetzt ausbildung
jährige der beim umrühren hilfst und ja
ich mache meist einfach so eine größere
bewegung zwischendurch und dann ich
rühre auch schon seit nach halbe stunde
möchte ich noch gar nicht bin am ende
meiner kräfte war
das passt und damit ich die abklopfen
muss nämlich meist so
unglaublich dass hier so aus
und dann wird es gut jetzt könnt ihr
hier diese dinge nehmen wie gesagt das
sind die kleinen bug ringe für zum
beispiel wörter brötchen und dann
einfach gleichmäßig verteilen
willst du
schön und dann durch das stimmen die
minis portionierer wie immer ja der ok
damit wird es ein bisschen länger dauern
dann könnten aber auch nimmt dann muss
man richtig großen eis portionierer
machen wo einfach nur mal so eine xxl
größe
ja
neue produktdesignerin haag nicolet
genau dies immer für die xxl größe zu
stellen ja
ja das kommt jetzt gleich den ofen für
irgendwas 35 minuten und wir können in
der zwischenzeit auch schon mal den tee
creme machen was magst du denn für
cremen so mein ding ist ja immer alles
was noch richtig schön cremig ist das
chopo und karamell es sollte per e mail
ist richtig mainz also dann bereiten wir
jetzt gleich eines zuhauses carroll
creme für das sind ja da habe ich eine
idee okay wir füllen weiter auf das
kommt den backofen und dann gibt's
gleich die scott karma klingt
[Musik]
derzeit auf den arm war sein sportfest
hier
da berichten wir da krieg ich sehen
scheide habe ich so ein tennisarm erhält
das sehen sie eine salbe richter mir
oben am ansatz ab der armut das ist
jetzt wirklich hier beton mischen
bei kuchen backen mit sally wie auf dem
bau ziehen so hoch die band kein problem
sagt jannik selbst so wunderbar und ab
in die röhre abgelaufen
[Musik]
also solltet campbell war der wunsch den
erfülle ich dir ich habe nämlich soll
das budget und die werden wir gleich
schmelzen nämlich mit 100 gramm sahne
dann habe ich die 250 gramm falsches 500
gramm als capone 500 sahne und sein apa
zum steif schlagen und
warum nimmt man nicht mehr sahne steif
wie früher ich hatte früher tatsächlich
auch mal sahne steif und es war immer so
ein päckchen wagenstadt für so ein
becher sahne und irgendwie habe ich aber
salat entdeckt weil sommerparty das ist
auch für quark für mascarpone für alles
mögliche und das ist einfach nur stärke
wärmebehandelt ist mir ein bisschen
zucker und das kannst du dir immer ganz
einfach merken pro 100 milliliter
flüssigkeit oder masse ein teelöffel und
das war für mich so bei enger mit 12 13
entdeckt und seitdem nämlich das ganze
geschäft 13
war susanne die das war kurz ihr drin
aufkochen und
das ist jetzt wieder so ein experiment
weil die creme habe ich jetzt so aber
nie gemacht also ich ja aber das wird ja
du ich denke also geht man dagegen
kaufen
ich glaube bei dieser bug v
online mehr ok
sehr lecker
ja sollte termin ist super und wenn ihr
solltet haben wir fertig habt dann könnt
ihr natürlich auch einfach
karamellbonbons nehmen vom supermarkt
oder eine karamellsoße die sollte man
dann vielleicht ein bisschen weniger zu
sehen weil das so sind natürlich flüssig
ist und ich wieder später keine flüssige
creme sondern eine feste
aber ich glaube die kann man jetzt hier
ganz gut einschmelzen und dann geben
lassen wir das abkühlen
werden so aufkochen lassen können aber
egal es macht das geht ja in einem ja
kommt man den kann man auch nicht immer
neuen nehmen oder schneebesen vielleicht
erstmal hier mit ja weil die brend sonst
an die sahne ja hört auf nicolet also
das ist einfach kurz darin schmelzen
[Musik]
genau das ist alles schon geschmolzen
der tolle karamellsoße die filme ganz
kurz oben und stellen sie ihm schnell
durch dann mal kurz ins gefrierfach und
wenn sie wieder ganz kalt ist dann geht
es mit der kleinen weit kann ich schon
so ja die können jetzt aber trinken aber
das lassen jetzt erstmal wieder
kühlschrank kalt abspülen warum muss
schlag waren immer ganz kalt bein weil
sonst wird's butter du kannst praktisch
die sahne nur schlagen wenn die kalt ist
weil nur dann dieses fett auch die luft
hält und ansonsten wird einfach zu gut
okay damit verbindet sich nicht wie das
genau physikalisch funktioniert kann ich
dir nicht erklären da lese ich gerne
nach aber es hält die luft einfach nicht
und dann wird zum klumpen mutter ist uns
alles und passiert
stellt kurz katze und bin ich gleich die
cremes abgekühlt ja richtig lecker jetzt
geben war weißt du was der artikel von
raska ton ist der das ich
hatte gesagt die ich auch danke und ich
ganz ehrlich wünschen nicolet auch schon
sagt ist die maske die eigentlich dafür
ich hoffe dass wir mal du rhin dass wir
im leben sagen die macher ist es das
nein der der mascarpone kann sich meinen
der frischkäse aber wie hört sich das
dann das geht doch nicht das kann man
doch nicht machen jetzt haben wir den
mascarpone da kommt die karamell creme
reihen die kalte die muss wirklich kalt
sein also da wirklich drauf achten sonst
habt ihr gleich einfach eigentlich wäre
es auch dass köln aber wenn das signal
das die genau
was ein zwölf deutsche sprache einfach
schwere sprache ist es ist ein bleibt
auswendig lernen
wir lernen von geburt an weil wir hier
aber für viele die hier das
unterschätzen der fremdsprache deutsch
als zweitsprache ist neben so schwere
sich das vornimmt projekt gestaltet ja
es ist wirklich so ja das berühren weil
es ganz vorsichtig und da einfach immer
darauf achten bei mascarpone es ist
nämlich so die kann ganz schnell kippen
und gewinnen und dann hast du irgendwann
einfach nur noch butter karamell und
weil es nicht schlimm aber wenn ich so
gut für die torte das heißt da auch
immer nicht so lange rühren
und dann dieses mal langsam die sahne
dazu gleich wenn das alles ein bisschen
verbunden ist
[Musik]
und jetzt kannst du gerne die sache
langsam zu küssen
und ich gebe es anna partner zu
[Musik]
ich bin backen macht einfach glücklich
deswegen mache ich auf die grenze
ja
[Musik]
ich probiere ich schmecke besser auch
weil man weiß nie
haben probleme genommen
und dann machen wir vielleicht noch so
ein pass ortet gerne vater sein dass ich
die kurve ja schon fast wieder versuchen
vom ganzen
[Musik]
sehr gut
einstellen für die bild will er wird ja
sozusagen gestellt die creme im
kühlschrank die tortenböden sind auch
gleich fertig wir warten bis alles
abkühlt und dann wird dekoriert so habe
die törtchen und die zahnseide von die
zahnseide
ich mache es mit zahnseide oder mit garn
und damit klar aber ich sage auch für
rinderrouladen ja ich habe das auch mit
zahnseide oder gar gemacht mit torten
säge hat man halt immer so gleich direkt
so die perfekte höhe aber ihr könnt auch
messer verwenden und kuchen messe
perfekt denn so schneiden sogar brötchen
auch sonntagmorgen wieder daten säge
das ist doch der hat hier ja
nichts war ich gerade eine der kamera an
23 das ist die das nicht dein fehler
oder so sind die cranberries drin wenn
man die inhalte analysieren erwischt
ja ich zeig dir jetzt mal die sowas
nicht auffällt du musst einfach wieso
knete und ganz anderes so genau keiner
hat s gesehen sehen kann man einfach
weitermachen und genau die schneiden
wird durch und führen sie dann mit der
creme und mit den übrigen faktisches und
dann bitte so eine schöne große
stumpenkerzen
okay okay
ich nehme noch am boden machst du auch
noch rein weil wir können die kerze hoch
machen gegen wir wollen ja
so
legt manchmal hier die hand außen an
dann stürzt sich so den teigen ein
bisschen ab und dann
genauso ich mag so gerne ich habe kein
platz mehr hier auf meinem team
sollten wir uns hier eine creme und
jetzt kann ich anfangen wo jetzt nimmt
sie dir am besten so einen drehteller
fax trage die creme drauf
zum zweiteiligen
das nimmst du für uns so ein
durch die schöne
durch die schön es waren die gleichen
[Musik]
sehr gut und dann her diese faqs und zum
start nur die torte
guck mal was warum das bei ihr klappt
weil du auch nicht das ding hier nämlich
du sagst aber auch nichts weißt du hast
mich erfolg vorgegangen trennen und ich
denke warum kommt nix auf ein löffel
warum habe ich einfach hier nicht auch
der spitze ist also
starken regens immer du dir mal die
schüssel da das kann jetzt bei mir
bleiben sollten
das ist auch übrigens der perfekte note
aller löffel das perfekte hotel messer
weil bei so normalen buttermesser und
die sind ja so spitze
und der staffel das ist schön
das gute ist wenn mal was nicht gelingt
in der küche passiert mir auch mal
und am ende kann man immer noch umbauen
wird draus machen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich brauch noch mal
lieber noch mal drauf
der vorschlag wird cupcakes machen kann
es wird jetzt eine richtige pferd
wird die olympia flagge
vergessen da muss ich wieder ein
bisschen kleben so schöne stunden kerzen
abzüglich sie tatsächlich gar nicht weil
das für das es wird nur eine sauerei
gleich
die ist dann halt schon was abgebrannt
abgebrochen
und schließt dann auch mit so einem
flachen boden ab
und dann
kann ich die nämlich außen noch
bestreichen
ich muss das leben darin mit dem hier
spielten
natürlich
muss ich noch mal ein bisschen seiner
partei machen doch es ist kurz berührt
nicht fünf gut
[Musik]
riechen spachtel so und damit klein war
jetzt das außen fängst du gegeben an ich
fange außen an weil ich da oben noch
festhalten kann
eltern so halte man kann ich noch ohne
dass ich mir die finger schmutzig machen
einfach rundherum und wir werden die
aber zwischendurch auch mal kühlen damit
die creme schön anziehen kann und
festwirt aber ich finde es sieht so
schon richtig gut aus
[Musik]
und wie hast du dich jetzt gefühlt
bisher super gut es geht gut voran ja
ich mache jetzt auch noch hier den einen
fertig und dann können wir drum rum
dekorieren der kerze reinstecken und
dann ist das ding fertig
was machen wir drum rum von doch
eigentlich nicht weil ich wollte
einzelne oder wolltest du mit von lukas
nicht so glatt dass das wirklich der
kerze aussieht du musst schon verkleidet
mit irgendwas also mit butter themen
social meinst du
aber das hat die frage ob du noch
buttercreme außenrum willst
wir können auch marzipan machen wir
können somit
du magst er machte aber
was soll
das eigentlich darauf dass du beim
backen oder wenn du sagen hantieren bist
warum lächelst du in deinen videos ja
ich achte oder gar nicht drauf und wenn
ich mir das video hinterher an coco er
fragt mich wieder jeder ob ich schlechte
laune hatte ja ich lächele immer
automatisch schon auch wenn ich alleine
packen ja das ist gut auch wenn ich so
in drei treffer was mache dann will ich
auch gesagt manchmal sagen auch leute
ich hab dich in der stadt gesehen die
connect ich habe mich aber nicht ganz so
böse geguckt und dann nicht mal
beobachtet euch mal selber wenn ihr
einkaufen weil ja man konzentriert ist
dann wird man nämlich bringen wir ja
auch meine flur
stehen aber ich genau und zwingend
machen wir jetzt mal schön hoch jetzt
mal rein nach einen stockwerk geben
darauf mit dem tag rein damit da ist es
vielleicht ganz gut wenn ihr ganz hoch
mit herr zu bauen willst und am besten
mit einem schaschlikspieß halt schon ein
bisschen stabilisiert habe ich mir mal
gemerkt bei dir du steckst du ja überall
rein liegen ich habe bei dir mal den
american cheesecake nach gepackt mit der
rp wusste
der klappt ja aber jetzt weiß ich
natürlich auch dass das bei mir nicht so
glatt geworden ist weil ich kein bug
ring hatte sondern springt für einen
kanister gerissen ja waren schlimm es
war okay ich mag das auch nicht für der
käse uhren in der mitte hoch gegen dann
fällt dazu sagen hast du das ist
natürlich nicht so schön aber es war
schon sehr sehr lecker und
dann hast du neulich hat diese logos die
spekulatius und buchen
das habe ich auch gemacht war auch sehr
lecker und
die grafik xtext hast du gemacht das
habe ich auch gesehen ja der karriere
geschenk bisschen gemogelt ja aber das
macht ja mal so ich stelle es noch im
kühlschrank woran kurz hier auf und dann
der chor er fertig
und macht backen spaß ja er ist mein
neues ding
nächste woche canal grande ja nie
kollege welt und ich bringe auch
versucht
und ich habe auch bald so eine theke zu
haben ich mache auch die komplette deko
nach hier
[Applaus]
also ich muss sagen mit buttercreme geht
es einfacher wenn man die torte nach
markt und buttercreme nimmt aber ich
muss halt aussagen was du manchmal
schimpften die und sagen immer
buttercreme aber ich bin produkt im
lecker also ja total du hast die lange
dünne kerze ich habe die kleine klumpige
meister wollen mich hier dass er
innerhalb dran das zeigt ich dir jetzt
guck mal ich weiß nicht wieso parallelen
sich so parallel
auch noch an henkel dran das
handy markt was habe ich gestern die mag
auch so bin ich mag
ja kommt es wird schöner sind ja ich sag
mal so es ist wie in pisa so ein
bisschen aber es gibt ja auch ich habe
mir jetzt ein städtchen rein wenn du es
auch brauchst zum stabilisieren so zum
bestreichen dann kann man es nämlich da
oben festhalten meine meinung ist auch
ein bisschen schief aber kaum sinn
kerzen kerzen sind doch nicht
kerzengerade
die sind jetzt massiv das wort heißt
kerzen schief was passiert
[Gelächter]
war
nehmt einfach buttercreme kürze
weitergehen wird fest das hält die torte
stabil klar mascarpone creme lecker
hammer aber bitte nehmt einfach nur
profitieren
oder warst du
als experte
so haben wir das dann
so
hier und
jetzt einmal hier gerade den java naja
ich hab keinen zum großen
mach ruhig noch ein bisschen creme drum
ich baue auf das das schiff
braucht mich jetzt auch nicht stressen
also ich kann unter druck keine ich bin
keine leistung unter druck wenn das bei
dir anders ist dann ist das okay aber
ich habe hier schon ein paar defizite
aber ich gleich dass auch guck mal hier
war ebenso groß war das eben proben und
deswegen dafür ich das jetzt einfach ein
bisschen aus wie ein normaler betrieb
wenn du das reine films denn das bitte
mal gerade im close-up das ist schon
gerade von der seite man wolle die
bildet sich hier wieder was ein weil ich
fertig bin gleich kannst du einpacken ok
komm ich sage mal darum haben wir wollen
jetzt heute hier auch nicht irgendwie
den schönheitswettbewerb für perfekte
kuchen gewinnen
aber da ist schon schön beobachten
ich komme da gleich hin weißt du so
einen blechkuchen jetzt auch getan für
heute also ein bisschen kirchen drauf
mandeln tue ich verstehe meine idee war
wir machen einfach so ein biskuit boden
ja dann kann man auch kaufen und dann
machst du dann eine dose obst drauf der
tortenguss da ist ja auch den zum
sprühen
achso wolltest du warten ja ich mache
noch drauf und alles okay okay ist so
ist tut mir leid ich entschuldige mich
also der sinn dieser kerzen torten ist
ja dass man dann auch so eine kerze
gesteckt und die später tatsächlich auch
anzündet
das heißt ihr müsst ihr mit buttercreme
einmal aufbauen oder in den tortenboden
schlechte ihnen aus in der mitte so dass
wirklich das rein passt und dann habt
ihr nicht so eine grosse creme schicht
drauf aber bei der creme schicht habt
ihr auch den vorteil dass ihr
das ganze noch schön mit dem muster
versehen könnte
hätte ich in ruhla stimme hat wer jetzt
schon fertig hätte welt zur feier haben
mit klößen
kann man das nächste mal machen ich
kochte auch mit der user beim nächsten
mal okay
dann machen wir das so
dann lass dich nicht von euch zwei
bekochen
[Musik]
nimmst du auf mann und kinder stück für
stück reißt sich mit einer
weltherrschaft unter nagel gibt es dann
packe ich schon
oder darf ich auch dabei ich genieße es
doch
ich muss die torte
noch mal machen mit buttercreme und dann
wird die auch wahnsinnig schön
aber das heute ist leider kein
meisterwerk aber du kannst
[Gelächter]
ach ich versuche das jetzt noch hier mit
den kerzen eine
andere farbe
ich muss gestehen ich hatte heute was
hatte ich hatte keine lust hatte keine
lust auf pippi langstrumpf ich wollte
heute cupcakes machen ich war im cup
cakes modus
und wenn ich keine lust auf sport ab
dann darf ich kenne dort immer dann
endet nämlich so
naja die partie am ende gesagt du sollst
kuchen
was sagst du jetzt
ja ja ja immer aber hier ist heute
die meisten schauen wie ich bank
argumentierte liebe zuschauer wenn ihr
jetzt so ein problem habt ihr weg jetzt
zum beispiel hier dass das nicht ganz so
waagerecht ist das heißt es euch nicht
auf geld aber es handelt sich ja nur um
wenige millimeter
wenn der sohn des blechs handhaben hält
siehst du dass jene differenz entsteht
das könnt ihr zwischendurch auf holz
dann so einfach hier ein bisschen mehr
von dem material auftragen
und blatt streichen
es muss viel auf die ecke und jetzt
kommt der trick das sind ergebnisse die
sie euch nie verrät
einfach so
und abziehen
dann noch mal so von der seite und seht
ihr das wird kein eurer gäste auf war ja
das kann man nach hinten drin
[Gelächter]
ich habe bock auf die kerzen und glas
oder besser gewesen
die das ist doch werde dir das verratene
tik tok
man kann die kerze oben draufsetzen und
da kann ich dafür meine aufbauen
ist dass
man das nicht nur sie advent als besten
licht brechen dritten
advent mit am besten die hütte brennt
mir leid was er die polizei einschritt
mir leid dieses torten rezept ich mach's
nochmal in schön aber kaum halt mein
gott mein gott wir hatten unseren spaß
und ich wollte halt weiß ich wollte dann
auch nicht so drauf behalten dass wir
hier so auf perfektion und keine ahnung
wie man muss einfach mal sagen es ist ja
jetzt schauen wir auch schon sehr viele
eltern zudem ihren kindern baghlan und
dann hast du auch das gleiche phänomen
die kriegen das ja wahrscheinlich auch
nicht so gut wie ich dass wir dann auch
wie bei dir
das ist ja dann auch ein gutes beispiel
dafür dass es um den spaß geht - eben
liebesnächte nimmt
wie so ein rinderbraten packst du das
darüber
seine mission macht das beste dazu
[Gelächter]
moment wir machen jetzt auch ein
gewinnspiel
wir verlosen eine nacht mit mir wenn ihr
eine kerze von weniger ist schreibt das
also erstmal den kanal abonnieren
überhaupt nicht immer nur kurze waren
auch abonieren nervt mich und dann like
oder dislike station ist alles
hauptsache irgendeinen daumen und auf
jeden fall kommentieren sagt was ihr
denkt
seid nett und aber hauptsache richtig
folgt nun mit kommentaren
also mir hat es ist sehr viel spaß und
ich finde wir sollten uns doch ein foto
machen mit unseren schönen torten
[Gelächter]
backen oder wir machen cupcakes der
vorschlag tätigkeit morgen
gewachsen
familien also
[Gelächter]
bitte
ich fühle zwar noch zwei drei torten
sowie ich zu führen wollte also am
besten macht es wirklich mit buttercreme
so wie ich gesagt habe die wird einfach
schön fest ihr könntet oder
zwischendurch gut kühlen und am besten
verwendet ihr noch kickbox sticks zum
stabilisieren damit die torte auch in
der höhe gerade wird und nichts schief
geht das heißt ich fühlte jetzt einfach
nur mal so richtig stellen sie kalt und
macht die nochmal einmal im gerade
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier bei der tochter macht so den rand
habe ich jetzt schön glatt und oben also
den oberen rand der streiche ich nicht
glatt in der mitte vor mich dann so eine
kleine lücke fürs teelicht und dieses
drumherum das bleibt jetzt auch so weil
dass er praktisch das wachs der kerze
ist und dann wird es richtig schön und
dann kommt noch der trip dazu und dann
wird es so wie ich sie mir vorgestellt
habe
du musst mal gucken von wäre seite des
anstalt wie beim baumfällen jetzt
das ganze kann hier kippte ja ich würde
sagen daher zerstören wir gar nicht
notieren kaum einen schneidenden kids
gerade
wenn sie die kib zurückschneiden das
geht schon
das schon so ein bisschen premiere auf
meinem kanal ok kannst du den teller
einmal hoch
ach komm ja ja also man muss sagen das
tut hier keinen abbruch die einzelnen
lagen
es bleibt einfach stehen und nicht
darauf zu finden
[Musik]
für die kirchen und mit karamell und
mit den walnüssen
doch
es lohnt sich könnte nachbacken ja
ihr könnt auch aus dem teig cupcakes
machen
cupcakes spritzen oder er macht die
kerzen torte nach ihr könnt auch cake
pops in anderen machen
einfach so
ich finds lecker und
ich würde sagen da jetzt wirklich sehr
konzentriert gearbeitet haben und ich
sehe so gar nicht dazu kam sich mit
fragen zu durchlöchern ich würde
vorschlagen dass ihr all diese fragen
mit den antworten in einem podcast hört
und der kommt nächste woche online am
donnerstag
an deinem dirty donnerstag ein bisschen
wir gleichen querverweis
jeden donnerstag ab donnerstag das
rezept findet ihr
blog de oder in meiner f ich mach's oder
in meinem neuen back oder ihnen
waren wir erfreut
bis zum 1
[Gelächter]
[Musik]